en el vídeo anterior sobre el plan
geithner explicamos un escenario en el
que un banco y permíteme escribir su
hoja de balance digamos que este banco
tiene un bien tóxico que llamamos a aquí
está su equilibrio que llamamos y aquí
arriba van a estar sus obligaciones que
le ponemos o y aquí estarán otros bienes
así que este es el bien tóxico
y explicamos un escenario tenemos una
exposición del 100% en a
y se tomaba un poco de efectivo se
prestaba a otra entidad digamos a un
fondo de cobertura por lo que esto se
convierte en un préstamo al fondo de
cobertura así que el fondo de cobertura
le debe este dinero a nuestro banco y
ahora tiene efectivo en su hoja de
balance así que ahora es un lugar de ser
efectivo lo vamos a llamar el préstamo
al fondo de cobertura
y esa es la hoja de balance del fondo de
cobertura y sus obligaciones son el
préstamo del banco
y ahora tiene efectivo por lo que puede
usarlo para invertirlo en este programa
del plan de geithner podrían tomar estos
no sé siete dólares y contribuir al
equilibrio del programa el té sólo
contribuiría con otra cantidad igual la
reserva federal contribuiría o prestaría
86 dólares y con los 100 dólares que se
tienen en total y bueno sé que el dibujo
no está sino demasiado claro pero aquí
se tendrían 100 dólares que podrían
usarse para comprar estos bienes tóxicos
el efecto neto de todo esto es que este
banco pasó de tener una exposición del
100 por ciento de este bien tóxico a a
tener sólo a una exposición de 7 dólares
mediante este préstamo este fondo de
cobertura o entidad de propósito general
como ustedes quieren llamarle y yo he
recibido algunos correos de colegas que
me preguntan si esto realmente puede
llevarse a cabo y mi primera reacción
fue decir bueno si hay alguna manera la
van a encontrar para hacer esto ya que
hay miles de millones de dólares en
juego aquí
y la estructura de esto está
incentivando a que ocurran este tipo de
hechos y yo pienso que el gobierno
quiere que esto suceda hasta cierto
punto ya que esta va a ser una
transferencia enorme de riquezas por
parte de los contribuyentes hacia los
bancos lo cual hasta cierto punto
solucionaría el problema aunque si las
personas se dieran cuenta de esto
realmente no estarían muy contentas ya
que todos estos bancos que funcionaron
mal sobrevivirían lo que quiero hacer
aquí es tratar de responder a esas
preguntas y encontrar una manera de que
esto pueda llevarse a cabo pero teniendo
en cuenta los términos que estamos
usando la terminología una colega mía me
mandó un correo electrónico donde me
señaló una cláusula de este plan donde
pareciera que se toma en cuenta las
circunstancias que yo estoy describiendo
en estos ejemplos
esta cláusula dice que los
inversionistas privados no pueden
participar en el pp efe el pp
efe significa fondo de inversiones
privado público por sus siglas en inglés
para comprar bienes de vendedores
afiliados a dichos inversionistas o que
representen 10% o más del capital
privado agregado en este pp y efe la
pregunta aquí que entendemos como
afiliados y yo busqué este término en
las reglas y regulaciones generales
promulgado bajo el acto de intercambio
de títulos de 1934 hay muchas
definiciones pero probablemente esta es
la mejor el término afiliado se refiere
a cualquier compañía que controle sea
controlada por o esté bajo el control
común con otra compañía y justo ese es
el escenario que estoy explicando acá
este banco realmente no controla este
fondo de cobertura simplemente le han
hecho un préstamo con algunas
estipulaciones y el fondo de cobertura
entonces puede hacer esto pero no hay
nada que ese banco pueda hacer para
obligar al fondo de cobertura a hacerlo
así que quizás este plan no funcione
otra cuestión es la definición de
capital privado algo que represente al
10% o más del capital privado agregado
francamente cuando yo pienso en capital
privado pienso más en términos de
inversionistas en equilibrio
quizás esta definición de capital
privado también involucre a los
inversionistas de deuda aunque lo dudo
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar una manera en donde
económicamente se realice esta misma
transacción el mismo comportamiento que
estoy describiendo aquí sin tener que
ser de manera alguna afiliado a algunos
de los actores aquí y tampoco otorgando
capital directamente a alguno de estos
lo que puede hacer este banco y bueno de
hecho permíteme dibujarlo este banco que
tiene el viento -que sicoa y eso es algo
que me vino a la mente después de
reflexionar en ello unos diez minutos
ustedes se pueden imaginar qué es lo que
se les ocurrirá a los bancos si es que
existen miles de millones de dólares de
por medio y si además sus carreras están
en la línea si tenemos un escenario
donde ésta esté bien tóxico y
económicamente quieren hacer lo que
acabo de describir pero no quieren ser
afiliados ni tener relación directa con
alguno de estos actores lo que sí
hace es vender o dejes obligaciones de
deuda garantizada que sean tremendamente
baratos podemos tener una exposición de
siete dólares en obligaciones de deuda
garantizada así que lo que se hace es
vender estás o dejes vendemos siete
dólares de exposición de nuestras
obligaciones aquí y veremos al detalle
de cómo funciona esto económicamente en
otro vídeo y como no vendí aquí voy a
tener un poquito de efectivo que recibo
de esta venta
la noción general es que se venden estas
obligaciones de deuda garantizada en
muy baratos recordamos que a son
nuestros bienes tóxicos y recordemos lo
que son las obligaciones de deuda
garantizada aunque ya se han hecho un
par de vídeos al respecto
esencialmente solo una póliza de seguro
sobre un préstamo o sobre una compañía y
si esta compañía este préstamo fallan
nuestra aseguradora pagará la cantidad
asegurada por lo que lo que hacemos es
vender siete dólares e no dejés y solo
para su información
muchos de estos bienes tóxicos que
tienen los bancos fueron originados
propiciados por los mismos bancos por lo
que son muy particulares para cada banco
individual por lo que un banco
definitivamente puede decir que vende
una o deje de algún bien tóxico y saben
perfectamente que cuando esto se vaya a
cero el banco será el principal
beneficiario si vendemos siete dólares
en obligaciones de deuda garantizada de
a qué voy a hacer bueno yo soy un fondo
de cobertura lo que hago es comprar
estas o dejes a un precio muy barato
después invierto en este programa así
que yo soy un fondo de cobertura y tengo
dos cosas tengo una inversión de siete
dólares en este programa en el plan
geithner y también tengo esta o dejé
esta póliza de seguro con respecto a
esta deuda así que dependiendo del
precio que tiene que pagar cierta
cantidad cada año pero el punto aquí es
que este banco puede venderla por casi
nada casi regaladas por lo que si este
banco lo hace este fondo de cobertura
tendrá una inversión de siete dólares en
el programa y después tendrá siete
dólares de o dejes que van a estar
protegidos por la policía de seguros
que le va a suceder a este fondo de
cobertura en un mundo en donde esté bien
y valga mucho dinero recibirán todo el
beneficio de su inversión de acuerdo a
este plan de geithner a lo mejor esta
inversión se eleva a 100 dólares vamos a
dibujarla de nuevo esta inversión de 7
dólares está aquí aquí 7 dólares del
tesoro
la reserva federal nos presta 86 dólares
y usamos todo esto para comprar el bien
y a cambio recibimos este bien aquí
tenemos el viento -que si coa si este
bien y termina valiendo mucho dinero
pues entonces esta inversión valdrá
mucho y no tendrían que darnos nada por
parte de la dg por lo que bueno todo
termina funcionando bien tenemos otro
escenario en el que esté bien
no vale nada esto falla si esta falla
esta inversión valdrá cero pero ya que
el fondo de cobertura tenía un seguro
con respecto a esta deuda o este
préstamo pues al fallar esto entra en
juego en funcionamiento el seguro y este
seguro me va a pagar por estas o dejes
que fallaron así que voy a recibir siete
dólares económicamente es exactamente lo
mismo que lo que expliqué en el vídeo
anterior del plan geithner aunque en
esta situación digamos que estos actores
están muy cercanos en cambio en este
vídeo lo que hace el banco es vender
casi
su uso de hesse para que puedan
asegurarse y darse este comportamiento y
esta fue sólo una de las opciones que se
me ocurrió hay otras maneras de hacerlo
si ustedes son un fondo de cobertura
separado imaginemos que a lo mejor
ustedes son dueños de todas las acciones
de este banco o la mayoría de ellas
también tendrán un incentivo de usar
este plan de geithner para comprar estos
bienes y asegurar las obligaciones de
deuda garantizada así que el tema
general aquí es que si tenemos dos
personas en este mundo privado tenemos
el escenario en el que la persona ha de
una transacción puede recibir cien
dólares y se deshace de una exposición
de 100 dólares y por otra parte la
persona ve
tiene en esencia una pérdida potencial
de siete dólares una exposición de siete
dólares podemos tener una transferencia
neta de riqueza aquí pasamos de una
exposición de 100 dólares a una
exposición de 7 dólares por lo que aquí
alguien está recibiendo una exposición
de 93 dólares y en este caso es el
gobierno que no recibe el gobierno solo
está recibiendo la peor parte
este es un gran subsidio de la
exposición
así que si tenemos estas circunstancias
el sector privado siempre tratará de
encontrar una forma de llegar a estos
términos y todo lo que hemos hablado de
sobre un banco que tiene una exposición
del 100% todo lo que tienen que hacer es
hacer préstamos u obtener seguros de
manera que le den a esta otra persona
esencialmente siete dólares de
compensación que le da la vuelta a las
reglas del gobierno y esa transacción se
llevará a cabo yo espero que esto no
suceda y quizás es posible que no ocurra
porque a lo mejor no estoy considerando
algo importante acá pero lo que digo es
que de lo que yo entiendo de este plan
de geithner es que hay un gran incentivo
para que esto suceda y francamente es la
única razón por la que funcionaría este
plan ya que como lo explique en otros
vídeos para un inversionista privado que
no tenga este incentivo de esta manera
el beneficio desproporcionado que le
está ofreciendo el gobierno no es
suficiente para invertir en pagar 60
dólares por un bien que solo vale 30 así
que esto no va a funcionar si este
comportamiento no se da
la única manera en que este plan podría
funcionar y que la gente pague de más
por los bienes es que se tenga este tipo
de acción